i saw uh what pepper spray does
it was published well i don't know if i
told you this story so i'm
i come out of a show i'm in venice i
come out of a show taking pictures
fight over here there was a tall very
handsome black man i was speaking to who
i
think was doing security at the venue i
was at okay i'm trying to be general
here
but he's a very good looking guy who
also happened to have been a singer
and was showing me video of him rapping
in venison he was
really good but more importantly because
i'm a little bit gay i was admiring his
bone structure and his
and his face yeah you know he's packing
very good looking guy yeah like just
one of those dudes who just looked like
an easy maybe six three but just
handsome and dressed cool
yeah so
[Laughter]
so i'm watching um these two guys
in a shoving match and it becomes loud
and then there's a girl
who is kind of getting in the way of
this
and the black gentleman i've been
talking to crosses the street casually
he's going to get in his car
and says you guys should move on you're
making too much noise
this is a residential area one of the
guys
gets pushed he walks over there because
the girl
kind of starts harassing him the girl
the guy who got who pushed turns on the
black guy
and gets in his face and puts his hand
on his chest
and the black gentleman who i had been
admiring very casually
very casually went yeah yeah like that
like lazy
shan champ just that
oh dude watch watch this he goes like
this he goes
the guy goes he does have a good night
the guy says nothing he just goes
he goes he goes and he goes next thing
you know he's on his hands and knees in
the sidewalk
the girl who's been harassing this guy
turns out to be his this guy's group
she comes over and goes you motherfu and
look she she [ __ ] her fist and he goes
super casual this guy's great it's way
better it gets weirder
i stop taking pictures i'd go across the
street but now i'm a little bit like
this guy is a professional
yeah and is he gonna be gonna do this
he's been around the block so i come up
with my hands up and i go hey
what's going on no magic spray no magic
spread
and he turns to the girl and goes wash
your eyes out with milk
you'll be fine everything gets in his
car i go dude
the cops he goes cops love me around
here don't worry about it it just
gets his car and goes let's go and some
other people get in the car
and he casually just goes dude paul's
about you jumped in this car
no how long did you guys
i'm looking at these i watched this guy
just kind of
casually drive off and i'm like um now
there's a gal here and i've got some
friends behind me there's this gal
i don't care about the guy because he's
crawled over to a foyer and he's over
there
he was an [ __ ] the girls here so i
say does anybody have any water my buddy
taryn gives me some water
so now i'm pouring water in her eyes and
i'm trying to keep her calm telling her
she's going to be okay
she's drunk off she deserved it though
she's drunk well apparently she used the
n-word
i was just going to hear that but my
friend who'd been there earlier
said she said something like where's my
you know blah blah blah and she it was
something derogatory did you take the
water back
no i did not i i kept trying here's the
problem i kept washing her eyes out
water doesn't do it doesn't do it oh
[ __ ] now
my girl my girl gets somebody drives by
my girlfriend with a
full fiji water bottle and smashes it on
her while they're driving
on your girl so she's all bunched up she
knocked her down
knocked her down this the water knife
she thought she got shot some guy some
[ __ ] just drove by when
we have it on video but i couldn't make
it the girl perspective
20 yards down the road so she's in the
car she goes i just got hit come on so
i'm like
what it's also feed you water it hurt
but it was sealed and they drove by if
you see it driving by the guy goes boom
that's the heavy issue
yeah and they've been doing it all we
found out they've done it to several
other women which is
just hitting girls you want [ __ ]
so so either way
yeah you have to go all the way to fiji
and bottom of the water yeah
cheaper you got the 12-pack of fiji from
costco
yeah i was like 30 bucks man here's the
problem when you're a good samaritan i
got in the car
we go to eat well the whole time i get
to the
the thing and well my nose and my eyes
start to pepper
yeah just from standing next yeah well i
was helping and i've
and whatever it got on my hands now it's
inside my nose it's so intense and then
i put
me i put water water makes it worse yep
you gotta have milk
so so i had to sit there and just my
face was on a fire have you ever
been hit with pepper spray no we were
cleaning out my grandpa's
uh after he passed away my dad's
cleaning out his garage and there's this
old pepper spray it's like from the
[ __ ] 40s but it keeps and my dad's
yeah
buddy my dad doesn't know that and he's
like shane's like
me and my brother's standing behind him
he's like does this thing even he's like
i don't think it works
and he sprayed it that way and the wind
went let's do it
that way so i'm like what are we doing
and then just
right in the eyes yeah write the paper
dude write the people i was like
seven how long does it last oh four
hours way too long
i'm still suffering from it today yeah i
see the eyes look at my eyes
i gave my ex uh pepper spray and my
daughter when she was
six seven yeah found it sprayed herself
and
went went into a seizure it was really
bad man they had to wash it oh it's no
punk there was no drugs
cause she thought it was like she
thought it was like lipstick or
something have you guys been pepper
sprayed
oh you have yeah i bet i was in a fight
in huntington beach with a bunch of
white dudes and they pepper sprayed me
and then they ran away it's an
interesting move to pepper spray
i'm putting the boots to your ribs if i
got to fight the big boy over here
i don't want dude i don't want any
trouble i i really don't
and then and now it's soccer soccer ribs
and then my sound effects with
every time and then my night's
over so is my morning yeah your night
out yeah the night and morning not in
the morning night in the morning oh i'm
not you're not getting
because we have spray for bears they do
you have springs they can spray from
like 20 feet
yeah you know see that's what they say
have you ever seen a bear
have you ever seen how big they are in
the beer just spray the beer well
the bear here is here it's it's
i wonder i wonder if it's working you
got him in that soft squishy nose
yeah what apparently it does work better
than they say you're better off with
pepper spray
when a charging mama bear is coming at
you or a big meal
apparently it does work but it's foam
and it'll spray from a distance right so
you're just like
but it's a can like this all good i
i there a guy did get attacked and he
said i sprayed the [ __ ] out of her but
she's still
she's still blown they'll doug they come
at the dome here yeah yeah
they come at the dome and you're you're
in some trouble well they
they at least they have that same spray
for like hornet's nest too where it's
real far away have you ever seen that no
they say it's supposed to work like if
someone breaks in your house have a can
of that
because you can shoot from [ __ ]
hornet spray or water spray
that's that's just works on burglars
yeah because
far far away and it really [ __ ] them up
really yeah
you need like the 30 foot spray i have
one up well it definitely works on
spider-man
sorry sorry man that's comedy
and the ant-man
hey let him have it let him have it let
him happen yeah
leave us alone literally you bully yeah
bully
daddy daddy's getting on a flight old
nashville spend today huh
of time in nashville daddy's doing the a
live big and hungry podcast and let's
stop doing that
no no it's going to be good it's going
to be good at sandy's good
sign in front of zany's and then with
the great steve burns who's very famous
no one's coming no no they're all coming
we're almost sold out
and then